this show is brought to you by texture
texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines anytime
anywhere using your smartphone or tablet
and the best part texture is offering
our listeners a free trial right now
when you go to texture.com Joey
that's right go to texture.com Joey
right now and start binge reading for
free that's texture.com Joey
show is also brought to you by datsu
Sara
go to dsgear.com Joey to get five
percent off all their extremely high
quality functional gear for jiu jitsu
that's made with hemp textiles they have
bags skis rash guards t-shirts and more
dsgear.com to get five percent off shows
also brought to you by anna.com go to
anna.com in East Cobra Church to save 10
on all their amazing optimization
products like Alpha brand new mood Tech
immune and shroom tech support
oh [__]
August 17th
2016 the devil was buried today
at Sea lit on fire drag
he joined Isis
then they stabbed him again
it's a church of what's Happening Now
what's up Lee you're still getting
flashbacks I'm still fighting I saw that
I really saw that
the music is bringing me back is what it
is
here we go ladies and gentlemen
oh [__]
it's Wednesday [__]
how you doing Lee
I'm back I'm I'm back to the world of
reality my main man Jake allenberg is in
the house
[__] my Champion my true champion and
[__] the type of [__] I like
Lee tell them what happened this is Jake
don't know what happened well Jake I uh
I took some allegedly took some acid the
other night alleged allegedly someone
said maybe that happened and it just uh
I don't know how much I took that that
might be a question for Joey because
here's the thing
there's a lot in this that I don't know
like I don't want to call it blacking
out but it was just
the trip that I was on
was not here
it was like I was vibrating I was
shaking
and I just ain't yeah what really Set It
Off was the music like I'm not even a
music person Joey really knows that
but like just
I don't know if you've ever done it you
obviously can't do it right now you saw
this listening but the music I did it
last weekend you did no okay but the
mute yeah it's uh
it was just and it wasn't like a bad
thing like it was I've heard of bad
trips before but that wasn't that like I
didn't I wasn't freaking out during it
no you just kept asking me if you were
in the hospital am I in the hospital he
would get like talk to me for a little
while and go am I in the hospital you're
not in the [__] Hospital what
hospital looks like this what hospital
is there a picture Led Zeppelin on the
[__] wall put me in that goddamn
house I didn't see anything I vividly
remember like as I was coming out of it
half of the room I could see as like the
real world the other half was still
swirly in colors and I was like oh [__]
and then you kept telling me the cops
are here
and he'd be like the cops are coming
because I would go in and out of I don't
think Consciousness but like like
understanding where reality was
and we'd be talking and he would just
look up and be like cops like close the
door the cops are coming and and then
like there's Sirens near here there's
Sirens all night he would look at me
like the cops coming I thought he called
the cops on me why would I [__] call
the cops on you my crime stopped I
wouldn't know but I didn't think I
didn't think to arrest me but to like
bring me to the hospital
you should have turned that music on
from The Shield cups
what's going on my brother
not much man it's good to be here it's
good that uh you know I mean I've known
you a long time I've known you I was
telling leaving you know years ago you
were coming to comedy shows in Irvine
yeah and look at Jake likes comedy and
stuff and then somebody said somebody
else told me they saw you got a comedy
show I'm like wow these UFC guys love
comedy and stuff because a lot of guys
come up to shows I saw Jake uh
what's his name last week at uh Denver
they were all there okay so I saw Jay
Shields there and uh a lot of the guys
from one of the schools came
Einstein was there didn't plan it so I
saw a lot of guys so you know the
world's a similar like I was telling you
get beat up the first two years the
first three years of common it's just
like it's just like signing up to for
[__] abuse yeah it really is you know
and you go to these bars I was telling
somebody yesterday about a bar in New
York yeah old triple it
I used to go there you could smell the
comedy in the air like it was that old
that old Funk that you'd walk in people
smoking cigarettes you could smell dried
beer and puke that's comedy you know
when you go to a nice comedy club now
you're like this is nice
and the family comes away you got like a
midnight right and you sit there until
two have a few drinks people stroll in
you know it's uh it's weird I'm
surprised more athletes and like
I guess though for lack of a better term
celebrities don't go to comedy shows
because what we get tortured well they
do they get tortured but here's the
thing like I always wonder why like we
always say like when someone gets in
trouble when they're at a club or
whatever I'm like why would you go to a
club a comedy club seems like sort of a
safe place if you want to have a night
out you'll get mommed a little bit but
if you come in late it seems like one of
the safer options yeah it's not it's not
it's not a bad time it really is I never
went to a comedy club before I got into
comedy
like never never I saw I watched comedy
on TV I throw Comics rehearsed in front
of a mirror and then some TV show called
you and said you have 10 minutes and you
just went up there unprepared that's
what I thought really yeah I didn't
think that you prepared I didn't know
what the [__] after I delved into it
more I was like wow this is what the
[__] it is yeah
that's a world I know nothing about but
you do but you don't right but you don't
it's so weird because it's the same
thing it's got to put the work in right
you know uh when I watch a fight I was
watching Nate Diaz against Michael
Jackson Johnson last night when I got
home it was on 11 30. I'm like huh these
guys getting hit in the [__] head and
walking around I get hit in the head I'm
thinking about Nebraska I'm thinking
about a bunch of [__] yeah you know
because you're doing it for you know
every goddamn day you know how to fight
the little you know when you just
breathe Shake yourself off get out of
the guy's range you just learn all these
things so comedy is basically the same
thing it's what you put in it's the time
on the mat that's it that's it that's it
same thing with [__] comedy same
thing you want to learn how to wrestle
you know it's so weird like when you uh
watch wrestling uh WWE and you do those
moves on your brother and you're like it
looks they make it look so [__] easy
on TV you know right well it was
interesting Joey because when you before
you you were talking about how you're
going to the advanced class now and
you're getting beat up but you like it
because it makes it better
Jake you had a bunch of fights that
might not have gone your way but I was
looking and you fought like seven or
eight like Champions people were
fighting for Champions like like just as
well you just fought Matt Brown Stephen
Thompson Joshua Kevin Gaston Robbie
Lawler yeah you know Rory McDonald yeah
there's no bums in your road
I mean it's it's one of the nastiest
divisions in the UFC I mean
and it's one of those things too like
you know it's such a small game of
inches I mean you could have a [__]
great fight and and make a mistake and
not get your hand raised you know same
same with like uh you you look like the
the Misha Holly home fight it's like she
was getting beat up and then she ends up
you know finding a submission on her
position and winning the world title
it's like so it's really it's just
there's the game is it's separated by so
many inches I mean I look at some of the
fights that
that I came up short and it was like
well I'm on my you know my mental
scorecard there was a lot of good things
good takeaways but uh I can use that to
move forward you know but it's like at
the end of the day I didn't get my hand
raised but [__] I made a lot of
improvements you know moving forward so
you Rose to the occasion sometimes right
so weird so they had Jiu Jitsu like I
said I went up against that monster and
I did something I never did before
really I did a knee Shield that's how I
was controlling it with a knee Shield
I'm like oh my god I've never done this
before sometimes when you go up against
the more Elite guys you work better you
know you just perform better naturally
you know it's so weird it's like when I
go to The Comedy Store and I go to a bar
when I go to economy store I got to be
on my p's and q's because they're
watching the best of the game on their
p's and q's and you know what I think
proves it your last three wins were all
performance of the night
all three of all the last three of his
wins so it must
like just for me well because I'm not I
don't fight I don't really know that but
I was just thinking I was playing a
baseball bat when you put the donut on
it and it's heavier and you split like
that's why you do it so it must when you
go up against these people now you're
like oh [__] I'm fine no I did not know
anything about the UFC cutting you and
you drive me out there I had heard that
for the first time yeah that's true
story now when I saw you at Higgins yeah
were you with the UFC
yeah I still was yeah it was
it was one of those weird things like
they didn't even
I didn't have a conversation with uh
with Dana or Joe until like eight ten
weeks after after the fight and then it
just kind of Joe had called my manager
and then so I would you know I'm
fortunate to have a good relationship
with Dana so I was like hey you know can
I can I talk to you and he's like sure
of course you know so he's always been
like open door kind of with me so I flew
out to Vegas and was like you know
listen I know
I've had some rough fights some that
didn't go my way but you know this is
not how the [__] story ends this is
not how
um this is not helmet and this so I said
give me give me one more shot and
and he's like all right you know he uh
you know I told him that
I wasn't you know I don't care who I was
like I don't care who it is
um give me one more shot and I'll and
I'll prove to you and he did so I was I
was fortunate enough to have a
relationship with Dana where he gave me
another shot but uh that's a true story
how long have you been like kings for
now
um I've been back there
uh at least the last year because I I
started training
um when I met you where were you 10
years ago what camp were you in uh
because you were probably yeah I
probably just started training uh
Munoz had a gym down in Orange County
that's right it was right when he opened
his gym and I was training a little bit
with with Rafael at Kings so it was kind
of but more so it rained so that was
kind of my first taste of uh Kings but
there was there wasn't very many guys in
this like very limited and it's like you
see it now and it's like there's [__]
so many killers in there now but
yeah it took a while for them to kind of
build that you know build the
the fighters but uh yeah cordero's an
amazing trainer though he's always been
good
so it's
it's been it's been a run man it's been
ups and downs but you got a great smile
on your face man yeah happy this was uh
when you got the call it was Matt Brown
you go what the [__]
what the [__]
yeah chance doesn't doesn't even have a
cousin
you know
yeah it was like I mean it's kind of one
of those it's like I'm all in we're
playing [__] poker I'm all in and I'm
gonna I'm either gonna [__] destroy
him or he's gonna beat me but it was one
of those again my back's against the
wall and we have no leverage it's like
this is who you're fighting like [__] it
all right let's do it so
but yeah I'm like he's he's a he's a
[__] he's a tough guy he's one of the
toughest guys in the in the game and
so it was kind of like all or nothing
you know this is what it is
[__] tremendous tremendous I don't
know where I was that weekend I'm gonna
go what because I would have thrown a
deuce on it I would have thrown a deuce
on it just to wish you good luck is it
you're a sweetheart of a guy you know
he's got to go for it he's got a [__]
girlfriend you [__] went for it like
you know that's the first thing ESPN put
on like I don't know who who's the
headline to fight
it was a co-head line and who was
headlining your card that card that you
went to oh Lord yeah nobody went
everybody went to this let me tell you
what happens this is a great fight so he
throws the kicking on my Jesus [__]
Christ yeah look at Jake allenberger
oh man that was yeah it was one of those
like in in my I was focused you know
there's so much [__] you got to deal
with and
like especially with fight week all this
all the media but I mean like for me it
was kind of like I'm not here to [__]
have a conversation with anybody to
shake a hand take a picture I I could
they can all go to you know they can all
wait until after the fight I was like
I'm here for one one [__] reason and
that's to to destroy Matt Brown so again
it was just focus was like hyper focused
more than any then more than I've been
for any other fight so it was like
walking out you know not I wasn't paying
attention to no nobody in the crowd
nothing didn't didn't matter it was like
Matt Brown and it was interesting
because
um I nobody actually I haven't told
anybody this but when he walked out
I was out I came out first and when he
walked out he he looked at me and then
he looked down
and I was like I got him I was like I'm
gonna [__]
I I know it was just one of those it was
kind of one of those reinforcing like my
confidence is high but I'm just gonna
attack him and
and he he did it again when they when uh
when Bruce uh introduced him you know he
looked he looked up and then he looked
at me and then he looked down
and I was like he he you could tell he
was nervous so I was like
for me I knew I was like I'm sure I'm
just gonna be offensive just attack
that's the that's the way you know
that's the way I gotta be I think I've
I've got in trouble in the past when I
get a little conservative and
you know start thinking too much get
[__] in my own head and and that's
it's not a not the time to think man
it's just just go execute sometimes I'm
watching the fight to be anybody and I'm
watching and uh
you know I'm a student of the head I
love the psychology of everything you
know during Bad Blood the other day they
asked Conor McGregor about his
head skills and he loves torturing
people and [__] but that backfires you
know when you piss on the fence when you
uh piss on somebody's legs as they call
it I grew up you know pistol in
somebody's leg I could come back and and
backfire on you I came from the old
school of the psychological you know
it's like when I first went to Jujitsu I
used to get anxiety Jay just tons of
anxiety and I've had somebody on top of
me like that are you [__] kidding me
right are you [__] kidding me this is
[__] brutal this is brutal and you
want me to do what look over my
shoulders are you [__] [__] I
ain't looking nowhere I'm looking
straight [__] ahead I See Stars I see
stars and [__] Eddie Chemtrails
little Chemtrails any Bravo talks about
and [__] yeah you know and then uh
you watch you know whenever two guys are
squaring off I'm zeroing in on what the
[__] are they thinking about I'd be
pissing my pants at this [__]
I'd be pissing my pants just going
around in circles and [__] around I
just go I can't take this no more I
can't stop breathing
so the psychological event like I always
say I don't like to
predict a fight to the weigh-in I'm I
love all that [__] you know when
Anderson Silva came out and put the mask
on against Vino he was done Vito went
upstairs and just put a nice pack on and
shook it you know that that's where it
starts right there the words are one
thing but there's little things that you
see let me tell you why I bet Diaz last
time Dwayne
when he went like this Connor flinched
and it was a little too extra of a
Flinch gotcha over game over I went I
did the comedy show and my logic was the
[__] weigh-in and jiu jitsu
that style of Jiu Jitsu that deep when
they're that good that high level that's
too much that's too much I didn't know
about it until I went to jiu jitsu and I
would get on top of a [__] 120 pound
woman that's a brown belt with four
stripes on it and just give her a minute
right just give her a minute she'll get
I choose to say get go put your shoulder
into me chubby watch this and next thing
you know she's grabbing my jeans and
picking her leg up and throwing me over
and I go once you're doing it that long
it becomes muscle memory it's over and
if you watch how he submitted them he
sliced it was like what what do they
teach you that the third week yeah they
teach that the third [__] week you
know that knee slice you learn later on
but it's it once but if I didn't if I
had never gone into a jiu jitu Studio I
wouldn't have known that right I
wouldn't have known that once you get to
that brown black belt level it's a
complete different [__] game
different world it's a different [__]
world yeah we were talking about uh
benil darush and the first like I I'm
much I'm much bigger than him but like
the first time we sparred
you know I'm I kind of beat him up a
little bit on the feet I take him down I
take him down and boom uh triangles me
and I'm like all right we go again like
this is the same room take him down
again [__] Guillotines me like send
it to me like four times in the first
and one around and I'm I'm [__] I'm
so pissed I'm so mad no and I don't know
who this guy is he looks like a guy off
the street you know and then I that I
come to see like I know he's a humble
black belt he's a you know world
champion 80cc world champion like okay
but like that's the
you know I'm I'm decent I'm not a a jiu
jitsu like extraordinaire but I'm pretty
familiar with like most positions and
but that sure that just I was like it
humbled me I was like these guys are
[__] a different this is a different
world different [__] world crazy
different world I I and I wouldn't have
known you know I like the UFC I like MMA
but I gotta tell you something when I
watched Joe Lauzon on YouTube doing that
crazy [__] he does I was like I gotta
try this I don't give a [__] if I'm 350
pounds I gotta try this yeah this is
tremendous this is you take a punch to
the face you learn how to take a halfway
decent punch the guy's momentum lands on
top here next thing you know you're
breaking this [__] elbow he's in
surgery getting his elbow done yeah the
momentum everything's against him he's
getting his elbow done he's watching his
hand on the floor waving at him from the
[__] table how are you good to see
you you shouldn't have [__] made that
mistake bye bye to yourself bye bye to
yourself yeah it's uh
I that's why you know and I believe in
that psychological little little things
that you see you don't look remember I
remember being a kid I'm watching uh
when I graduated high school you weren't
even born yet Cody fought Larry Holmes
he wouldn't look at him the Great White
Hope all the white Irish people in my
neighborhood were marching [__] were
taking it back and next thing you know
he wouldn't look at [__] Larry Holmes
he just looked at the floor and
everybody in the room was like it's over
we lost our money around oh [__] he
won't look him he won't look him that's
it it's all those little [__] things
you know and this is the kingdom
and the sins of the king of them because
they're subtle right he doesn't talk he
doesn't do anything they're just very
subtle he would just mess with you he
would hug you even if he'd hug you and
invite you to a barbecue you're leaving
there going what the [__] just happened
I'm about to fight him tomorrow night
let him into a barbecue
the thing that's weird for me was like I
don't know if you watch the embedded
stuff uh I like it I think it's really
interesting I like well I like it all
but the the weird thing for me for this
one is like I've we've talked about how
the Diaz brothers like do like
triathlons and they go running all the
time for Connor's Camp he has like this
mansion and he has like this ring put in
and they brought press in and he was
doing this drill where he was getting
punched in the stomach is that a normal
drill and just screaming yeah that's a
normal thing to do like I just seemed
like it seemed like he was doing like
theatrical stuff this thing pretty cool
and Nate Diaz was just running for like
12 hours at like the like the 24 Hour
Fitness he just went there for like 12
hours and just stayed on the treadmill
until it like broke
that was the one thing to me it would
just seemed like a little bit too much a
little showy yeah but but that's also
his Persona so and he's great like it's
it's not that it obviously works for him
but yeah that's that's why I think
people some people like Diaz more Jake
what's a training camp consist of let's
say I'm fighting at the Garden what's
the date at the Garden just November
right yeah just I'm just talking here
hypothetically just hypothetically
well you know it's there's a [__]
there's a lot of moving Parts
um right this is why I just even the
people at home I just always wanted to
ask somebody you're cool as hell we
could just talk yeah what is it oh okay
let's pretend it's like November 21st or
something because I know the plane
ticket's a [__] high I looked already
for that [__] week 17 1100 what the
[__] to go to New York
November 12th all right November 12th
it's what August 17th so we basically
got 90 days right we got 120 days let's
say they call you with the fight you can
fight November 12th when does training
camp usually start yeah this like this
last fight with with brown I I trained
for 15 weeks but I had about six weeks
like I wanted to get like a good six
weeks of training before I even
scheduled anything to kind of get it I
was you know just getting back in
routine and uh
but yeah I would say like typically 10
weeks is good amount of time for
uh from strategy from like
training in all the aspects but um yeah
like like Monday through Friday is a
typical a typical week and then
something extra Saturday but uh
yeah each fight is is so different too
because with the opponent you know
you're trying to get guys that mimic
that style or
you know like with brownies like six one
or six two like [__] tall and that's
not very common at 170 so you know I had
to find some guys that were his high you
know as far with those kind of guys so
there's a little bit of homework to do
before we even get into that eight ten
weeks of training but uh
it's a lot I mean for me specifically I
like to to do uh you know I'd say at
least 12 weeks of training some people
can do six or eight but I feel I felt
that I feel better the more you know I
can bring my weight down a little bit
more get a little bit more of a routine
as far as like running and that kind of
stuff before we go into like the high
intensity what do you walk around that
um usually
about 190 195 around there but when I
still look light now yeah [__] I'm
probably 200 right now wow you look
[__] light like damn 200. I better
not never get robbed because I can't
describe the guy's [__] way I'm
terrible wait I think 180. yeah no I'm I
mean it's
it's deceptive though because I'm only
emulator I'm a lean guy but like yeah if
when I'm training I try to stay around
185 about 15 over but you know it's like
it takes a little bit of time to get
there you know before we get into that
like high intensity because
yeah so if I can do like eight six to
eight weeks of uh like the aerobic
training where we do like the lower
heart rate 150 area for like 45 minutes
you know three times a week like so you
for me I kind of build the low the low
base and then
like the probably for the last six weeks
you're like high intensity Sprints like
we do the I work with Nick Nick Curson
and he's in he's in Torrance and [__]
that guy's changed the game for me I
mean it's never that good now he worked
on the the guy from Oakland yeah
right and and so I I was just for me I
was just watching some of the stuff that
he did with like the balance you know
manipulation and the foot the feet work
and so I was like yeah this is
interesting so I kind of was just
watching videos online and
and was like this guy you know he seems
pretty pretty smart and and did a lot of
pool workouts you know so I was like
yeah you know I'm I'm getting older I'm
not I'm not 20 anymore these these
[__] guys coming up here training MMA
when they're like 12 you know
but uh I liked his approach as far as
what he what he did so I went down and
met him and uh we started doing a little
bit of stuff kind of got to gnome and I
I was getting stronger and and
noticeably faster you know like he talks
about building the kinesthetic awareness
like being able to train your nervous
system if that makes sense and uh I
could see a noticeable difference like
within a couple of weeks so I was like
wow this is great and so his like the
way he his you know the periodization we
would do these [__] I I would watch
uh how Phil dosanos do these 110-yard
sprints on that football field
and I'm like I've never done 110 yard
Sprints 110 yards 110. and I [__] I
grew up playing football I played every
sport yeah it is I've never I've never
ran for nothing
so yeah my for the first time I ran I I
was I was [__] toast in inside of a
round I was like
and it was it was the different world I
was like this is this is crazy I mean
they know them going to the track three
days a week and doing this high
intensity but you got to build your way
to get to there right and plus for me it
was like
it'd be like going to you know day one
in Jiu Jitsu it's like you're not gonna
start doing these you know flying
triangle flying onboard day one it's
like yeah there's some progression there
but yeah Nick if you [__] eat
he really uh kind of changed turned
changed the approach my approach to
training and uh and especially in
conditioning so but it's all the fast
twitch but he was he was big on building
the foot strength you know and uh
just just a smart guy you know and he's
been doing it 18 years you know and a
lot of a lot of guys didn't don't know
his story but if you look at his
athletes like you can see the
transformation like with dosanos he's
worked with him for like three years now
and I mean I saw him because he was like
you know he was a good fighter and he
went to [__] great fighter now he's
he became the champ and I was like well
he's doing something right you know so I
would it made me more Curious on uh on
his training approach
it's so weird how much goes in that uh
the public doesn't know or even
understand you know
how much work goes in it's [__] crazy
I can't even think of a recovery like
it's five days two three different
things a day you know football you do
two weeks or two a days right in 90
degree weather you run up a few Hills
after the two weeks is over that's it
it's three to five that's it this is
[__] crazy now when do you
when do most people start to wake up
no I I would say probably six weeks six
weeks from the fight
um at least you know addressing because
Mo you know a lot of guys and I think
that's kind of that that the whole the
way differential that's kind of changed
a little bit I think in the last year
more so because
you know with with people thinking
um being heavier where you'd get the
you'd have an advantage but you know
strength plays such a little part these
days it's like speed and endurance are
obviously the biggest things I think you
know in my opinion I think GSP kind of
changed the game the way you know you
saw him
him doing his track workouts him doing
everything but uh it was all like had to
come down to endurance because like okay
guys even if they could keep keep up
with him for a round you know by the
third round you're you're toast he's
he's gonna he's gonna do what he wants
so you know I think the evolution of the
sports change and you know
guys becoming [__] faster and quicker
and having better uh
you know better better coordination and
just uh you know coming down to
endurance I mean you look at the the
McGregor the first fight with with Diaz
and he he was doing good doing work in
the first round and gets gets tired and
it's like
you know that that's a different weight
class and and it shows you the endurance
you know Diaz those guys are known for
their endurance and I think it's it is
it's a huge you know that's one thing
even going into the Matt Brown fight is
like well [__] they're like if you hurt
him you know don't
don't sit here and Sprint for for a
minute trying to finish him because he's
you know you know how tough he is and
he's he's no like he's known for holding
on
for hanging in there and catching up and
end up getting you know getting guys in
the way around but
you know for me I mean that was that was
approach I kind of took they're like
because they're like we know you're
probably gonna hurt him like this is
Rafael Cordero like you're gonna hurt
him but don't don't waste all of your
[__] energy trying to try to just
just try to finish him because he'll
come back so it's kind of I had to be a
little more take a step back be a little
more intelligent on on that fight not
before these fights you train every
discipline like Muay Thai
Jiu Jitsu you wrestle a few days a week
you know you Spar a few days a week you
bet pretty basically I mean that's
what's always [__] me like you have
so many different disciplines
to draw some people train with the geese
some people say hang on trying to
[__] gee they ain't gonna believe in
the MMA with a gay you know everybody
has different [__] things and that's
what I respect I respect the hard work
you know just the strength and
conditioning [__] hour would kill me
three days a week never mind
boxing and [__] jumping on boxes you
know and then you dye it and you know
it's just
and it's not just strength and
conditioning it's like going full out
because you're like you can't like half
ass
that's not the reason and the whole time
you got to be careful that you don't get
hurt yeah did you see [__] Cerrone
doing that Wave Runner thing I'm like
he's gonna [__] kill himself before
his fight but I had a question what's
the best part about a training camp
because like obviously like I'm a suck
at least part of it must be tough but
like what's the best part
honestly I look forward to going to
sleep like sleeping seriously is [__]
as stupid as that sounds like I really
look forward to like a good night's
sleep because like that's where you you
get a good night's sleep that's where
you recover I mean
and [__] I mean the worst like the worst
part I mean I you know the skills and
stuff is fun I like I like wrestling Jiu
Jitsu it's it's like it's enjoyable but
like that when you start doing the track
workouts and the conditioning that's
like the [__] most unenjoyable part
and you know spawn is usually fun too so
it's like you can find some enjoyment in
most of it but you get so you know your
body it's so [__] taxing yeah I
literally look forward to going to sleep
I don't blame you I look forward to
going to sleep when I don't do all that
stuff but
but it's um
do you ever like what is it I I'm and I
apologize I just don't I haven't
followed your I have only followed the
UFC for a few years have you did you
ever have to pull out of a fight for
before for an injury at the end of a
training camp
I did one time what is that like that
must suck
yeah it was
you know it's just one of those things
just it is what it is you know it's you
don't plan ever to get hurt but [__]
happens I mean I actually uh had a tore
my hamstring yeah yeah it was one of
those weird [__] things I just like
slipped weird and like like you know it
was after training so the [__] mats
completely covered and this was at Kings
and uh I had slipped weird and like felt
a little pop and I knew it just it felt
weird and I was like I get this checked
out and like yeah you got a partial tear
in your
semi-membranosus and I was like oh [__]
I don't know what that is but all right
that doesn't sound good
it is uh
how long have you been in the UFC tent
it's amazing how long you've been in the
league like 2009 wow it was my first
fight against uh Carlos Condit
no [__] yeah in in
it was one of those things too it was a
two like two week notice fight and again
one of those I got nothing to lose the
[__] yeah you know and and he had they
had just the UFC just acquired the wec
and conduct came into the UFC and he
lost his first fight by like split
decision to Martin campman and so then
his next fight was Chris Lytle he got
hurt and so then they like my manager
was like hey we you know do you want to
take this fight of course so I was
basically brought in to be the guy to
get beat up or give Carlos Connor to win
you know and it ended up being like one
of the top top 30 best fights of all
time and we had a [__] like I I I
dropped him like three different times
it was a good fight I mean I I
definitely got tired like
between this I've never been so tired
between I I I had you know two weeks of
training but between the second and the
third round I was [__] I remember
exactly how I felt I was like I don't
know how the [__] I don't know how I'm
gonna finish this this this fight I
don't know how I'm gonna
I can barely breathe it felt like I was
breathing through a [__] coffee stir
I was like I couldn't even see but I I
was I'd get you know I'd give in the
first round
giving him hell and the second round was
close and then the third round he
definitely won but again one of those
things that was like nothing to lose
let's do it
but if you haven't seen that you should
you should go back and watch it the
first round is
it's a crazy first round I kind of sort
of remember it I sort of remember
because I remember when he came in
against captain on a Wednesday night it
was like a special fight night and then
right when he fought again he you know
that's
like I said you've had some [__]
brawls man so and you know listen here's
the beauty about the UFC here's the
beauty about comedy here's the beauty
about if you play the [__] tuba
here's the beauty about it if you play
the [__] guitar in a band you know
they were supposed to cancel Seinfeld
after the first year
sometimes man it takes some people a
little longer to catch on than
nothing wrong with that Nate's been
lurking for [__] right for nine years
Nate was lurking and watch Michael
Johnson Connor and now he's walking
around with his [__] dick out and
they're giving him checks swinging his
dick yes swinging this deck and it's
like I always say just keep showing up
right there's gonna be [__] bad ones
and there's gonna be good ones do you
think every time I go on stage it's a
[__] Masterpiece it's a disaster it's
a disaster 5 out of 10 [__] times but
I know that going in yeah but every once
in a while the sound system is great
Mama sucked your dick she gave you a
nice steak the hotel's good the
weather's nice you saw some good friends
and all the stars get aligned man
and once the stars get aligned you've
done your training you already popped
your elbow you already got knocked out
you already got submitted you already
done it all so now that comes you just
look at yourself in the mirror one thing
oh I got three good [__] years I want
to [__] mope around the unemployment
line well I'm on this [__] slap
[__] and get what's coming to
me I've been doing this for 10 [__]
years exactly and that's what happens
and one day it all comes [__]
together and you know and that's what it
looked like for me for you I saw you
those three fights and I remember like
that third fight when you lost you
looked a little like you couldn't even
believe what was going on in your life
but you found the [__] hole man you
found the home down there you got back
in your stride all the stars were alive
and there's Matt Brown and the next one
and the next one after that whether they
line up against you because you found a
home you have a [__] home you're not
a [__] orphan no more hang on
Glendale and [__] I know driving to
Redondo Beach and then [__] hiking I
gotta learn Jiu Jitsu in Las Vegas
listen this one stop shopping yeah the
least time you had you know if you could
do everything which you probably do yeah
because Nick Carson's over at Kings
pretty much right yep so all the other
person's got to show up is the
acupuncturist that's the only other ride
you got to get then maybe to go freeze
your [__] shoulder like Joe Rogan
somewhere that's it you got one sub shop
and I couldn't Arrow you know they tape
you there
it's uh you found the home man and it's
no looking back from there that's it
yeah you take your humps and your
[__] bumps a hooker sucks a thousand
dicks and also in one day she's a Madam
you know what I'm saying she's running
the joint down she's missing a foot you
know what I'm saying but she's running
the joints she's getting 10 she's got 30
chicks sucking dick for her you're so
inspirational
I gotta drop it like it is you know
hookers people are at home going Joe but
I'm a hooker well let me tell you what
happens to you all right next thing you
know you end up in North Hollywood with
a little Chinese massage parlor with
Scott's tape on your eyes like the
[__] Mexicans they're [__] beniana
you ever go to Benihana there's no more
Japanese people up there
oh
then I want to do it no more I don't
want to work as many animals I want to
be a math major
[Laughter]
I'm [__] believable actually I sat in
the hotel I sat in the hospital for two
[__] days tubes up my nose I got a
cloudy [__] nose again I suffered for
four weeks everything was working out
now I'm back to being stuffed up again
who [__] straws they put up my nose
with stitches oh yeah
Jesus Christ I've gotten a septoplasty
on my [__] worst operation ever yeah
they put the straw down yeah like the
plastic tubes they sew in there yeah
they sew it in there for the lover I was
miserable for like two months really
yeah
I've been okay I've been breathing I
mean it's not as bad as it was I'm
breathing I'm not [__] I'm getting
that black gas out of me that's the
killer you know what I'm saying
you don't breathe that's what happened
dogging for years I wouldn't [__]
exhale
just be grasping so that black ass just
sits in your stomach nothing [__]
moves you get stuck you need to see the
acupuncturist
and that's it I was listening to uh when
you had Dr Belize right yeah yeah she's
[__] awesome now did you go see her
also no I haven't I I I I I got the book
like I wanna I wanna reach out to her
but uh I heard her on your Showboat a
couple of times and she seems great
though you know man she's she's on to
something she really is on to something
there's something about it because I
asked a couple of jujitsu guys like
Einstein the other day and I'm saying
goes guess what I do now she goes he
goes I do the exercises at the end of my
workout
and I get back on the mat and it's
amazing it clears everything she has
different breathing for different things
you know in the book she's really
interesting she's not the something
right she's on to something you know and
yeah
it's it's uh you know you you have to
pull from everywhere especially when
you're a professional like yourself you
have to read from everywhere you don't
know one little thing might help you
mourn anything yeah
that's a that the whole world's like
fascinating to me eh and it's growing
look what you said about listen it's not
no more [__] jump on the table ten
times do 10 behind the neck presses or
185 push that they got it down with
[__] signs these kids are going to
school now they go to work for somebody
else who's got a different science so
they mix The Sciences pretty like you
like [__] Bruce Lee you put together
your own health jikuno they know
everything right you know over at
Alberto's they got that technical
Fitness
same [__] thing yeah you know your
hips your arms you swing them around
with a [__] bat when I first got to
Alberto's I couldn't put my arms up I
take them back I swing it around your
[__] head and back and forth and it's
they say it's a smart we're growing now
that's it jump Jacqueline's dead it's
over no more [__] jumping jacks we're
on to new [__] things that's it this
is the future man they put [__] heart
monitors on you they put stuff you know
it wasn't uh junior taking blood after
every [__] workout and I could see
what's in your blood with the oxygen
right well it's a different levels man
well how do you decide which what what
to do because there's so many options
like try everything but some of them
must be crazy some of them must like be
bad for you like how do you how do you
filter all that stuff
yeah I mean like you know it's
experiment try it out that's right you
do you just try everything well you know
incredible credible Source I guess but
uh I had a buddy who's a professor down
at Cal State Fullerton and he uh I would
talk to him about
just different aerobic like how to how
do I train smarter breathe better like
because that whole breathing game was
[__] foreign to me it's like trying
to learn Chinese like
but he's like when you're you know you
see these Runners and they exha they
work on their focus on their exhale
because he was like the faster you can
push the carbon out you know the it's
not about the inhale it's about the
exhale and I was I was like what like
how the [__] and I'm just find this out
right now but it was fascinating so
which when I listened to Dr Belize I was
like man she you know I got her book and
then and read the book and I was like no
this is this is [__] great like I
want to learn more you know it's it can
only help Dr Belize you know where I saw
you at Higgins they teach the stem of
that okay and that guy will change your
breathing around he's like Dr Belize it
would be interesting to get all three of
them together and then there's somebody
else
that does something with that so it's
police
Systema and there's somebody else like
what uh Hixson talked about it's
documentary there's that uh what's that
that style of yoga I forget what it is
that one the Breath of Fire they have it
on Santa Monica Denny proctopus goes
there like Denny does a lot of yoga but
a lot of breathing
for his Jujitsu and he mixes it with
kettlebells and he does Jiu Jitsu that
works for him right you know the
breathing but oh in technical Fitness
see what they talk about is the exhale
focus on the exhale exhale because if
the more you push the Exile out the
cleaner air go in so that's what they
always talk about so yeah it's that even
that you know for two thousand years
you know God knows how much that's
[__] changed who was it a couple
weeks ago every time Chief oh Holly
Holmes ah right ah
yeah
there's something to it though yeah this
is whatever works Serena Williams has
been doing it for years
take that you [__]
yeah
no word on you so you're still training
now or you're are you uh what do they
say suspended for 60 days no not
medically suspended yeah not suspend not
I mean usually for like 10 days or
something but uh yeah I've been kind of
a couple days a week you're not nothing
I was I was traveling I was in Omaha for
a couple weeks and then
but yeah getting getting back into it
you know a couple days a week take a few
days off if you need it so but yeah next
week I'll start training I got a few
buddies of mine fighting
um I've actually Benny beniel darus
they're both fighting in Mexico City so
they're getting ready for that so oh
yeah
um
October November something like Mexico
City you know the elevation
down there
um
Tony Ferguson
oh that's gonna be a fight
all those 155s get me [__] crazy that
150 that's a another hell hole of that
that division's [__] insane 155 or
170 you're mingling in some weird Waters
there right you know 145 you got out
though you got the other guy you got the
blonde guy you got a couple guys but 155
those first five guys if they haven't
got together
like those five guys just said [__] it
[__] this UFC [__] we just want to go
from town to town and be people the [__]
up it would be monstrous like you know
the Russian with the [__] hat would
throw you out a window once you landed
[__] the Brazilian would be kicking
in like a soccer ball then they'll just
get Alvarez to come over and headbutt
you and hit you with an album I mean
that [__] 155 is crazy insane even
that other that other yeah what's
another good fight that's coming up
Michael Johnson against
Dustin Poirier
that's a good fight that's a good
[__] fight right there my friends
this I like those kind of that's what I
like I can't take those big [__]
things no more and then everybody's
testing nobody knows what's going on oh
that's the kiss of death those top two
they're always in trouble right you want
to be like the second fight on the card
get a check go home yeah right watch it
while they have the while they're
fighting [__] man card that's
it that really pissed you in a bottle
you're [__] up in the stands doing
heroin drinking whiskey [__] yelling
and screaming and [__] what's his
name what's uh what's the guy in the
Middle With The Tuxedo Jimmy Buffett
yeah yeah that's the con I would never
want to fight that now listen listen
Dana I want the second fight I got [__]
to do I gotta get my dick sucked I gotta
mingle through the crowd doc listen you
fight this you fight the second card you
knock a [__] you just get a
tuxedo with no pants and you just walk
through [__] the arena after that you
know what I'm saying yum yums for a week
always I would always I'm like put me
first I'll be first yeah I'm at two
o'clock two o'clock if I had to wait
there all night to fight some money I'd
have a nervous breakdown like 9 45 I got
a fight I mean this is 6 15. you know
what that's like oh [__] I've been up
since 6 15 the [__] morning I gotta
find a 9 45 at night and then the Heart
Attack by four that's a [__]
nightmare listen Dana you know that card
you got for [__] Q4 that other
channel put me on that [__] Fight 2
30 no Rogan no nobody just uh just send
somebody I don't give up yeah dude
you're on YouTube yeah we'll do it on
YouTube
you know what [__] it you don't have to
film it [__] it you I gotta wait till 10
to fight somebody are you [__] nuts
if that's what dilemma I got now listen
when you when you're a young comment can
get 30 and somebody looks at you and
goes and you call in for sponsors The
Comedy Store and they tell you on the
phone like like nothing
yeah you spotted 12 45. okay 12 45
Tuesday 12 1 p.m 1 a.m Thursday and
you're like okay
you have no idea what that's like that
means you have to fill your schedule
that's what makes you a really good
comic because now you're like okay I can
sit at home with Mama till midnight and
bore myself to pieces
I could just start the night out at
eight right and go to a Mexican room
down in [__] Orange County and then
shoot up and do the ice house and pick
up 75 bucks and then do the 11 30 at the
[__] Laugh Factory and then go to The
Comedy Store and by that time they're
running late she got an hour away you
talk to your buddies maturity made a
little money plus you did four or five
sets I could never imagine like [__]
fighting at 10 o'clock at night I mean
in the second fight or maybe third if
you throw me a little bonus Dana White
just draw me a little something cash
right when I get off right there in the
room waiting for me you'd have the 6 PM
flight back to LA if you were the
fighter like you'd be like Dan I have a
6 PM fight oh yeah damn I'm going back
to Burbank yeah I'm on the red eye the
bird Bank eleven ten I can't be waiting
around for press conferences
let me go home I don't want to sit here
and sit across I'll do 1 30. I'll do
130. yeah no I don't know how they do
that sometimes when I see that [__] I'm
like how do they do that all day some of
those fights in Brazil or something like
2 30 in the morning
and I like because when I fought in
Atlanta we didn't go out till 11th my
fight was like 11 30 at night and so I
was like
I bring a [__] pillow to the locker
room I said I went to sleep when I got
there I was like I'm not gonna sit here
and anxiety over [__] waiting you
know it's like I went to sleep and then
wake me up an hour before the fight and
warm up so wake me up before you go go
yeah
Wake Me Up Before You Go-Go there's no
reason to have my hair wasting time dog
the first time I did a movie you know I
moved to L.A I didn't know nothing about
nothing nothing about I didn't know
nothing about movies I watched movies I
play that's my favorite movie right
there yeah I want Josie Williams look at
me it's [__] beautiful it's [__]
beautiful look at that Savage where is
he today [__] at Starbucks eating a
[__] Mac and Chino we don't even have
an outlaw Josie Wales in 2016. 50
[__] years ago we had to download
Josie Williams look I'm killing
everybody Indians white people Mexicans
he didn't give a [__] and nobody nobody
said nothing to him nobody tweeting you
know Ellen gennaris says one [__]
black thing everybody gets madly he's
shooting every [__] nationality
nobody to say nothing Clint Eastwood
nothing
anyway
it's so that was what happened with Jiu
Jitsu at first
I had to go at eight o'clock at night
eight o'clock at night it's not a good
time for Uncle Joey you know what I'm
saying by that time there's been a lot
of chemicals a lot of reefer smoke my
anxiety levels were behind that food in
my stomach every time I went to
Jiu-Jitsu I thought I was going to die
finally won this and [__] it there's an
11 A.M class somewhere and that gets it
out of the way I get a little anxiety
about 9 45 I pop a little baby aspirin I
drink a little [__] energy drink and
I shoot down there like a [__] like a
guy in the electric chair I'm gonna die
anyway I might as well die and I'll burn
those [__] cages that's the real
truth for the first year in Jiu Jitsu I
would hug the cats
I would have a will you know what I'm
saying I thought I would be [__]
panicking I would be panicking but
that's what got my dick hard that for
years I hadn't panicked
I haven't panicked in years we live in
this [__] beautiful world when I was
21 I used to panic every [__] night
I'd throw a window through a rock and
get chased Rob somebody's [__] Coke
you do something your heart beats my
heart don't beat no more so I kind of
like that Panic stage you know I hadn't
Panic like that in a while now I get a
little whip by one o'clock I ain't
panicking I'm ready to stab a
[__]
once I walk out of Jiu Jitsu who's gonna
stop me who's gonna stop me what are you
gonna say to me pull over are you
[__] crazy I just got I was I was on
the bottom end of a [__] triple choke
people ask me what my best submission is
getting choked I gotta get choked I even
told the guy yesterday I'm not American
economy [__] joke man I got bad
shoulders
foreign
I gotta imagine because [__] I love
going to comedy shows but
there's got to be some [__] anxiety
are you [__] anxiety is my middle
name
I wear underwear so I don't pee through
my pants are you [__] kidding me
anxiety but see
it's like
controlled anxiety I can't imagine
okay I can imagine sitting in the locker
room and watching the other fights and
hitting the pads and giggling and [__] I
can dig that that's I'm tremendous at
that that's my [__] world I can hit
pads and crack jokes and do Rocky
balboas and everything
that walk to the cage
would not be a good situation for me
some again I watch you guys and I go
what would I feel like right now
and that's Terror that's Terror once I
touch that mat and I'd walk up those
stairs instead of doing that little
dance I'd just be breathing heavy my
breathing would be out of [__]
control by that point I'd be
hyperventilating without even doing
nothing
by the time he was searching me
but then they're searching my underarms
and all that [__] I'm [__] I'm
getting anxiety they would even stop the
fight they would sit me down and give me
oxygen because as the guy would be
touching me my heart would be beating
that much of my chest I can't take that
type of [__] listen I love I love
smoking pot
and
I don't mind having a [__] beer do
you know why I don't have a beer when I
go out and do comedy or bring weed with
me I don't do good with cops are happy
so to not have any nonsense I don't
drink and drive why take the chance the
way you're drinking yes a beer I'm gonna
come out now that wine I can't walk that
line
even if I'm straight I'll fall apart so
now I got beef now I got beef because I
can't handle that type of [__] but I
know that going in you know I'm saying a
lot of people that's why I don't know
how the hell you guys do it I get
anxiety
not to drive down to The Comedy Store
not when I get out of the car
not when I [__] get my water from the
bartender and say some stupid remarks
not when I
I walk up the stairs to The Comedy Store
that little three stairs three [__]
stairs a grown man three stairs
time I get to that tops there the room
drops it's like I got vertigo and I'm
like oh [__] we got a problem
and he's got the light
that means he can get off at any [__]
time I'm trying to catch my breath you
mean to tell me I gotta walk 15 more
steps to that stage I can't even stand I
gotta go sit down that's how bad the
anxiety gets for me
like that's how bad but once your foot
touches that [__] stage
and my hand touches that microphone it's
like getting punched for a fighter it
has to be the same once I hit that
microphone and I asked him what the
[__] up [__]
done anxiety's done it's that Force four
minutes
that's how
it's half Jake what's your anxiety like
what what how does it develop for you
where's your Peak yeah that's I would
say
the walkout's always the worst because
everything
it's funny because I'm surprised to hear
you guys say that that's not what I want
you with the Apocalypse Now when they
land the first time and the kid's like I
don't want to go I don't want to go
remember that dog remember that he's
like I don't want to go and then I get
the [__] out there [__] sucker that's me
I would I would hit the front thing of
the [__] walk and I would go I don't
want to go that's it go there will go
without me then I have to rip my Adidas
well there's a Nike
read box they'd be ripping it come back
Joey come back [__] you
yeah it's you know what it's funny
because
I've had 16 fights in the UFC and it you
think it would get easier but it doesn't
it I mean you can deal with it like you
just learned a deal with it but the walk
is always the same like I never have a
problem going to the arena in the back
room I [__] we cracked jokes you know
keep it light it's [__] you know the
back room is my buddy back there with
turkey sandwiches talking about the
eighth grade getting my dick sucked
behind the church look at me you're
gonna knock him out Joey I'm a [__]
bad [__] yeah I'm unstoppable
like my carrots I'm there that whole ego
thing is me it's that [__] walk to
the thing it would kill me so I'm loving
that you're telling me this [__] it's
that that's that's it because
it's funny I I've been working with this
guy he's a sports psychiatrist down in
San Diego and uh his dog names Dr lardon
and he's [__] brilliant but he always
talks about stay in your bubble you know
what I mean and and I didn't really
understand what that meant what does
that even mean but he would be like you
know you're here to do one thing you're
not here to [__] be on Twitter you
know social media you're not here to do
any of that [__] like because it's
so easy to get caught up in that [__]
you know that celebrity kind of bubble
but he's like you're here for one reason
that kind of helped reinforce me but
yeah I don't get I don't get it I don't
get anxiety in the back you know warming
up it's smooth we're cracking jokes
keeping it light and it's only just from
that from the locker room to in the
October that's that's it that's the only
time when you're like your heart rate's
High you know people are [__]
screaming you know wanna want to throw
chairs over there you know but for me
it's just like I'm not I'm not looking
at anybody I'm not even looking at the
[__] camera I'm going in there and
it's but that's yeah that's really the
only time you know once once the fight
starts you're just moving you're already
going just like when you you know you
grab the mic it's like
let's [__] dude let's go okay so once
they searched me
um how's your anxiety when they search
you
check the mouthpiece you hug your
coaches right right there that last
coach I just hung on to him as hard as I
can I'd say coach I don't want to do
this like I did Coach don't make me do
like I really would and have to hear him
say to me Joe
yeah like I would know what to do once I
walk up what do I feel like once I'm in
my corner there what do I feel like I
mean it's it's definitely intense but I
feel like like when I look at my coaches
it's like they look at me in the eye and
it's it's confidence you know what I
mean they're like we're here because we
[__] believe in you you know what I
mean it's just like let's you know been
here as far as preparation we've done
[__] 20 you know 2 900 [__] rounds
so it's like we're at three rounds you
just got three rounds that's all it is
so then you you know it's it's and for
me it's always been I'm My Own Worst
Enemy if I start thinking about this
[__] and this [__] and
you know but like I said that when I
started working with Dr lardon he kind
of cleared a lot of that overthinking
over analyzing just that's that part of
the brain that [__] too much
he kind of kicked that out so it was
just like
keeping it simple you know
um
and just standing staying in the bubble
I mean but it's definitely little
anxiety I would say just on the walk
I'd probably be more like anxiety than
when you stop
so once you stop all right [__] rip
it off you just want to you know some
guys just run to the [__] Octon rip
their [__] off let's just want to get
back to walk over yeah that would be the
only way I could do it if I just ran to
the [__] time
sprinted balls out to the Octagon
stopped and had him like when I go give
blood that's my [__] hatred right
there but I've already figured out a way
I looked the other way I put an iPod on
I listened to Santana the same [__]
song and in a way I'm just giving him my
arm like I just give them my arm and
look the other way and I feel a little
bit this last time it was [__] up
couldn't find the [__] veins so it
hurt a little bit they had to stabbed me
like four times [__] I hate all that
[__] like I can't deal with that stuff
but I go to acupuncture
because I don't want to overcome my fear
that's a horrible [__] feeling you
can't gonna [__] I would go to the
doctor's office and Dodge and go around
the corner and say I didn't feel like
getting a needle one time I went down
and did the checkup and ran out before
the blood test they were calling my ass
what the [__] happened to you I don't
like blood tests man I gotta go get a
shingle shot it's killing me because I
know it's Gonna Hurt it's in the [__]
shoulder that means I faint that means I
faint I could feel the serum going into
my [__] arm you understand me that
means I go down
you're thinking about a right hook
what's that you're thinking about
throwing a right hook hit the nurse oh
no no oh it's terrible I have my my
childhood doctor
because I didn't like needles either
so I I would always tell her to like
tell me when she's gonna give me like a
countdown she just tried to do it so I
smacked her and she stabbed herself with
the needle no she did not wow Dr Nathan
you know you know what's actually even
worse
like I I've never liked needles but you
just [__] deal with it but like
my son he just turned one and I hate
watching him get [__] vaccines I
don't know
oh yeah like oh my God you get pissed at
the doctor you gotta restrain yourself
right you can you can [__] stab me
with a pool cue but like watching my son
you know you put him down and then they
[__] poke him with a little needle
and then he starts he looks at you like
what the why the [__] am I getting you
know what I mean like it's your fault
and that's the worst that gives me
anxiety I'm getting anxiety
[__] up right now you really really
want us all the doctor huh call it like
you'd freak out at the doctor
I've always listen I've just told the
doctors the truth that I have a phobia
when I walk into a doctor's office and
they check my blood pressure they go
what's going on with it and they know I
got white coat [__] whatever the [__]
and they give me 15 minutes they talk to
me then they come back and my blood
pressure is [__] perfect
I just don't like it I'm just as I was a
kid I just don't [__] like it this
guy's been my doctor for 16 years 17
years so I started to like him about 10
years ago he's great he's a great guy
you know so now I don't mind if he the
chicks that take the blood out I have a
relationship with them you know how you
doing what's going on how you been how's
your daughter that type of [__] so I
just give him the arm now you know but I
I couldn't even [__]
now let me ask you one last question
about this fear [__] wake up in the
morning on the morning of Fight Night
a little brutal in the morning that
morning maybe three minutes of what the
[__] McDonald's
not so much I mean
it's more uh yeah like I said I really
don't have any any issues like any
anxiety I should say until until you
tell you they're [__] all right
Ellenberger you get on the X you know
the cameras right there like until you
do that I really it's all pretty
manageable but you know everybody
everybody's different I know guys that
[__] you can't even talked to you on
fight day like they'll [__] freak out
or they'll be thrown up in the trash can
but you know everybody's different you
know I I like I said I I really I'm
pretty decent until the walkout you
gotta just [__] let's do it let's go
it's almost like you you don't wanna
there's too much [__] wasted time you
know too much waiting you're just like
let's just let's do it
I'll just I'll just run I'm just gonna
Sprint now
I get I get
even if it's a little gig I get a little
anxiety in the morning of
like what the [__] am I gonna say I
don't really want to do this [__] no
more
I should just quit and start selling
[__] cars what the [__] am I gonna
borrow for I mean I really go through it
really yeah for about eight nine minutes
and then I come to my senses
and I say I'm the luckiest [__] guy
in the world you know I got a great job
and I get to go down there and [__]
around on stage and then everything sort
of works out but no no no I get it
terrible and that's great then you broke
it down because I've never really asked
to find them before like game day
weekday the weekday announce the fight T
and you get a little anxiety on the
phone I mean I don't even think about it
if somebody like I said that'd be great
till they called my name to run down the
[__] cage
and once I got in the cage I'd
hyperventilate myself and tapped myself
out I think Bruce buff would come on
what happened I just tapped myself out
dog my lungs are going too much let me
give some shout outs and get the [__]
out of here before tracking track it
hits big thumb Terry John Cutler my girl
Cleo one by one podcast
ookie spooky will be seeing you in
Austin on the 15th of September Jeff
Cordero bobolingus Rob keys and my man
Matt Baker up there at Matt Baker BJJ
putting it [__] together
what do you got planned for the weekend
Lee what I got for the weekend
um
I don't think I'm gonna go see that
Suicide Squad movie
don't do it don't do it it's terrible
people saying it's bad
I don't know I don't [__] it though do I
live with the movie credit to you I know
I honestly haven't thought towards the
weekend yet when that is date night this
week I probably Saturday because we're
going to the ice house Friday we are you
coming with me absolutely
I'm happy you're coming up and [__] I
felt bad about what happened to you like
it wasn't uh
because you know I've done acid before
but it affected me for a little while
but it didn't get me once I got the air
and [__] I was back to normal I would
skip Luke Magoo I would have been fine I
think the second dose was what sent me
over the top
uh and then then I got sick and but
thank you for taking care of me oh I
can't leave you like an animal we've all
gotten sick at one time or another
somebody's always taking care of us yeah
we just laid down on the couch and
wouldn't that be doing them I called
them in the morning he said he got a
pizza some wings at five to two yeah
because I was like I can't all right
because the last time I tried this
happened I think I didn't get that
messed up but I tried to take an Uber
home it was too scared so I was like I
don't know if I could handle looking at
someone yet because it was like
like you can see the video like I was
shaking like it was it was like a weird
it was a great it was fun but it was
like a intense experience I didn't know
if I could handle being in a car with
someone
so I decided to order pizza and then
like that that was kind of cool a little
scary
and then and then I and then but then I
had the best Lyft driver
he was like a 40 year old black dude
with a purple car playing like old r b
music it was awesome
what'd he charge you like three bucks
it's awesome so now you went over the
lift you're a [__] communist you know
first you're hanging out with Uber and
then you go over the lift you're like a
[__] you're worse than America
one week when they're jumping up and
down with Bernie Sanders then they hate
him all of a sudden now they're in bed
with Hillary everybody Bernie's saying
this is done you [__]
Hillary no but then why did you [__]
get off the Bernie Sanders vote get a
petition going let's revoke this [__]
you know what I'm saying everybody just
tapped out one day like [__] it
you know we don't care huh we'll jump on
Hillary's dick now what the [__] is
wrong with America you just don't give
up on your [__] people like that but
you do now this is the Millennials
ruining [__] they even gave themselves a
name the Millennials look ruining [__]
ruining [__]
[__] around going to places with
tight jeans on and [__] meanwhile
they're closing [__] restaurants that
matter what's closing now this week
like [__] Steak and Shake or
something like that I think TGI Fridays
are closed they deserve to close down
those [__] things in fact the same
boring as [__] menu since
onion rings and [__] who still has onion
rings on their [__] menu it's 2016.
it's 2016. something [__] [__]
I'll eat the [__] out of somebody rings
I gotta tell you Joey all right
a few years ago I went you were you were
playing with Joe Rogan this was in Vegas
okay and it was [__]
one of the it was the [__] best show
that I'd seen ever like you [__]
killed it and I'm not just saying that
but like it was one of those like when
you were on like you were on and
everybody [__] knew it you know what
I mean like you just
I was [__] I heard it was I was
trying to catch my breath I was [__]
dying so hard but it was it was I think
it was wanna maybe Rhonda was fighting
it was in Vegas but it was I think it
was a few years ago I was there with
Hannah Gracie and
but it was one of the best shows by far
that I've ever seen
I lose my mind in Vegas on a Friday
night because you could because you
could yeah sometimes Joe's cool with it
and sometimes Joe ain't cool with it you
know what I'm saying like but sometimes
most nine out of 10 times like [__] you
then when you did you know
no you can't give a [__] listen it's the
same thing when you to do what you did
against Matt Brown did you give a [__]
no not at all what did you learn from
that fight
what did you learn from that fight and
from the two previous fights before what
did you learn to not give a [__] it's
the and once you've been there like once
you go down that street it's an ugly
street because you never raised to be
that type of savage but it's 2016 [__]
you want to run with the Jews you want
to pick up an envelope you got to go
deep you know what I'm saying you want
to run with the Jews you got to be a
little on the beach side you know you
know this is it you got to focus on what
the [__] you want and when it's the time
you're here with me because I love you
but I knew it I had a funny [__]
feeling on this [__] I might do
something crazy he might do something
[__] crazy and you did it and that
just goes to show you that when you want
something
absolutely you zero in on it you zero
[__] in on it you can do whatever the
[__] you want it's just amazing that we
always leave don't we always talk about
people know the uh everybody knows what
they need to do you know everybody talks
about the iPhone the iPad you know I
what the [__] you know what you need to
do but then we dig around we beat around
the bush I'm gonna do I don't want to go
there I'm gonna do this I'm gonna you
know what you gotta [__] do you know
what you got to do and you did it
perfectly you know for years you watch
uh
fights and the first [__] three
minutes you want to shoot yourself
professional people like Gentiles like
you know they're measuring themselves
out
that's a smart attack you know
um Rashad Evans once said that Michael
John told them you know if you hear them
boo you're doing your job correctly
listen as a friend every time you see
that bro the best three fights I ever
saw were in San Francisco they all ended
within two minutes somebody was yelling
and screaming stad somebody was bleeding
within two minutes and this guy don't
trade no cardio he just knows you're on
the street you gotta do or die [__]
it's me against him and the bus is
coming so I gotta fight this guy before
the [__] bus gets here and that's
just you know everybody makes this big
[__] deal about it you want to go out
there and [__] get it that's it go
out then [__] get it man period
that's that's it it's but we never
really want to face that
for the first time after 25 years I've
been doing comedy the right way I listen
to my sets I take notes and it's a
complete different world for me like
Jesus
I hate hearing my voice
but if I gotta it's like every 30
minutes I listen to it you get one gem
what's a gem Joey even if it's one
[__] line right I'll take it the rest
of this should get built to the toilet
I'll [__] take it I don't even know
what we're talking about no I know
people because I mean even my coach
they'd be like if you just stop [__]
giving stop trying to control if it
makes sense to control the outcome just
let you know just [__] go just like
nobody's gonna stop you then it's like
one of those things you're kind of uh
the control freak party who's like oh
you know I don't wanna it's like [__]
that when it when it you know and then
it's like you see it when you just when
you just [__] stop giving a [__] you
know people are waking up to a to a fat
guy with a pin light in their eye you
know it's like they're waking up from a
canvas nap and that's just like I gotta
stop I gotta stop giving a [__] it's
really it's it's it's true though it's
I gave a [__] so I was about 22.
I thought life was real you're like yeah
like life is [__] real you gotta help
women across the street and put your
jacket down in a puddle when you see
some [__] hot bread walking and see
how that lasts that have back flies on
you then when you put the [__]
heaters on you play It's called Playing
for Keeps you know it really is cloud
play if it keeps and you rise to the
[__] occasions
it's just beautiful
what do you see brother
what do you see next not an opponent
what do you see for you what do you want
to [__] do man you want to go for
this 170 you got yeah oh yeah no it's
[__] this is it I mean I'm I'm ready
to go and uh
I want that world title so it's you know
I'll fight again for the end of the year
and uh you're right you goes down yeah
become the world [__] Champion
yeah be a Savage eat [__] dog bones
for breakfast be a [__] Junkyard Dog
[__] it and we're down to Kings man it's
it's a [__] New World down there too
it's got so many killers I mean
[__] world Champs and now it's like
it's it's it's there you know you put
together three two three wins and we're
right there fighting for the title so
I'm in I'm all in if I was 25 I'm gonna
be a heavyweight I just got on there and
smack Red Doom every day like let's go
Bob what's the story [__] let's do this
[__] I let him [__] me up I apologize
they come back a week later Bob there
you go what [__]
that's how you get better fighting
[__] verdum every day right because
that guy will definitely catch it he'll
catch you he'll let you [__] slap him
he'll go down on purpose he'll let you
hit me bam he'll go down on purpose and
you'll see that leg lingering
that legal linger that little leg it's
like a dead leg it just lingers and all
of a sudden as you go to see if he's
alive or awake that leg just comes up
and throws you in a weird position next
thing you know they got the bottom of
your shirt with one's finger and they're
pulling it towards them and the other
leg's doing this and now the hand is
grabbing the bottom of your [__]
socks and you're going for a [__]
loop it's it's a it's [__] great Hey
listen man it was great that uh
you came on and it was great to see you
back on the uh there was nobody happier
than me I went right to Twitter where
was this [__] because like we used to
have Twitter conversations today
performing Thursday night [__] yeah you
want to come by yeah early show who else
used to come there was one kind of Hume
was around then yeah kind of human come
to the Friday night shows in Irvine
there was somebody else the tap out guys
yeah guys
they're they're kind of you know they're
doing their thing
um the little guy had a show Dan yeah
yeah he's been busy I haven't I haven't
I haven't talked to him in a while
though
I haven't talked to him a little while
no and the tall guy Skyped yeah what the
[__] is Skype uh I don't know they got
like that 20 mil and just moved to
Brazil they said [__] it we're gonna go
eat outside balls no more wigs I spent
enough on wigs it's over we're going to
[__] Brazil which I don't think it'd
be Brazilian he used to come to all the
[__] shops and one day he disappeared
I guess when they bought him out they
said listen here's an extra 10 million
don't come to the UFC show I'm gonna
send you the best Bernie Sanders [__]
bar let's we send you there nobody
leaves there all right yeah man thank
you thank you it's an honor I appreciate
you having me nah you're [__] great
and uh I could see that you're back and
blah blah blah blah blah blah but your
family and uh good luck to you whatever
the [__] you want to do Lee what's going
on with you I actually I have a new
website you do yeah yeah what is this
called no what is this what is this
website of death cult it's calledly side
Consulting in Minecraft
my buddy Robin Johnson creative made it
for me so if you're interested just go
to Lisa Consulting Lisa because and what
can I get consulted on I'm starting a
podcast I've been doing a lot of Skype
consultations and it's really great I've
just it's really a quick hour and just
get you the equipment what if let's say
what if yeah
me and Jake want to start like a porno
live webcam okay I sense things listen
to this listen to this idea you always
hit me with [__] ideas let me give
you an idea how about two hot chicks and
a chubby dude let's pretend you will put
you in the middle I like it'll put you
in a table like this and two chicks or a
guy with a big dick or some chick just
bang and do sexual things and you never
it like you and her name like right now
he's doing the this move like it's if
you guys could be here you could smell
it casual sex yeah like casual sex
that's the podcast and charged by the
minute like 52 bucks by the minute oh
are you saying we can use this table for
that no no I didn't say this table this
table was a Catholic table I'm a
Catholic you can't have dirty [__] on
this [__] table you baptized today
yeah you baptized the table so I'm just
saying Lee that's a show you should
consider or maybe you and a hot girl and
she sits right there and looks at the
guy's [__] and says stick your finger
in it and you have to cheer you know
whatever I don't know and people have to
pay by the hour we're wasting the time
wasting their time we could be doing a
porno [__] podcast with live [__]
streaming and live announcers
not a bad idea only a nice [__] slick
Jewish person would think of something
like that Lee that's how I roll see I'm
a Cuban Julie I've been telling you that
for [__] years nobody thinks like me
give me the paperwork please for the
love of Christ I'm trying to throw your
codes you're looking around
thank you you know unbelievable people
you don't know what I have to deal with
the other night I thought he was going
to die on me I didn't know what to do he
had me almost scared I'm sorry no I
don't give a [__] I'm gonna tell you I
would have put a car I would have rolled
up in this carpet picking up to the 170
you know man I don't know what happened
to him he left in the Volkswagen I'll
get some [__] D'Agostino fingerprints
and put them on your door and that's it
I don't know what happened
I know I'm in the well
he left the wheel I would do a will that
night I would have done a well with your
little dead Jew hand I would have taken
the pencil and wrote Lisa yet he left me
everything
thanks to Pizza we all Benji thanks to
Netflix we all binge watch
but now with texture we can start binge
reading
trust me it's about to be a thing when
it comes to magazines you know what you
like and when texted you can get all the
magazines you want in one super
convenient place texture has completely
reimagined magazines giving you the
Articles stories you really want all in
one place plus plus interactive features
videos and recommendations just for you
the texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines
anytime anywhere Breeze through hundreds
of your favorite magazines including
back issues and pick the articles that
interest you the most
Texas texture has made it easy for you
to find articles you care about I don't
just get to read you know like uh Road
and track and Mac world all right I get
you also get Fitness Field and Stream
Bon Appetit Cooking Light Cycle World
Sports Illustrated Kids I mean the list
goes on and on and on and on sign up for
texture right now and gain Insider
access to all the content from the
world's best Publications the best part
is here is Texas offered my listeners a
free trial right now when you go to
texture.com Joey that's right go to
texit.com Joey I'm gonna give you a free
trial right now what I'm going to give
you is a meeting entry to all the top
magazines including back issues and and
who do you thinking dealing with bonus
video content start binge reading for
free right now when you go to
texture.com Joey again that's
techshit.com Joey the texture app is
entirely digital so it's super
environmentally friendly way to consume
the best magazines and articles again
texture.com
for you [__] BJJ Savages listen to me
from geese to a fanny pack to my bag all
I wear is the dot to Sarah the bag is
tremendous I got the water bottle I got
the other water bottle I got my protein
powder I got my knee braces in there I
got [__] my wall in there I got I got
a cool towel in there I got another cool
towel I got my nose spray in there they
got a thousand [__] Pockets you
understand me it is tremendous they even
give you a bag to put your dirty [__] in
there so your regular [__] doesn't touch
you a little rash guard that smells like
10 dead Iranians nah you don't have to
have that [__] in there you take it out
you spray your little Lysol in there the
fanny pack from datsu Sarah tremendous
when I fly when we go to Austin Lee
we're gonna [__] put the fanny pack
on and take pictures and roll what do we
got in there rolling papers lighters a
phone an extra phone an extra phone just
in case we're in Mexico the rolling
papers in a baggie in case the plane
goes down matches waterproof the ones
you like that's what you put in the
[__] knapsack you understand me in a
fanny pack anyway if you're looking for
high quality rash guards a tremendous
hemp ghee a tremendous Jiu Jitsu bag a
tremendous fanny pack the list goes on
and on go to dsgear.com right now take a
look at the great stuff they have if
there's anything you like go to the box
and press in Joey boom I get five
percent off your order who's better than
that you understand me again let's say
you want to do some Jiu Jitsu but you
also want some supplements go to
honor.com right now there you have it
too they deliver right to your [__]
door Alpha Brain 100 guarantee shrimp
Tech shrimp Tech sport shroom Tech
immune and the list goes on and on and
on but I ain't got the [__] time in
this Jake Ellenberg he's gonna get on
the five minute South what you need to
do is go to honor.com right now and
press in church boom get 10
[__] percent off and this [__]
gets delivered to your door like a
doctor you understand me all you need is
a Chinese hooker with the wrong address
if you're living like a [__] doctor
anyway I want to thank Dr Sarah I want
to thank [__] on it and I want to
thank my people over at texture.com go
to texture.com right now and get your
little Magazine app and [__] read
your way to death you understand me well
is it the first Joey texted.com Joey and
that's it I love you guys we'll be back
Sunday night stay black stay beautiful
and that's it I want to thank my man
Jake Ellenberger and my main man lee
Syed and that's it stay black have a
great weekend
For the Love of Money
The OJ's that's what you're going to put
on I'm sorry I didn't get anything
and my [__] go all the one
it's a cold world out there that's what
my [__] is called
foreign